[Musique]
bonsoir à tous leurs du 7-8 journal de
tv soixante dix huit pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale et régionale tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 5
juin et des compétences fusionner
désormais une célébration commune
yvelines et hauts-de-seine ont organisé
leur première fête inter départementale
du numérique
elle se tenait hier à marnes-la-coquette
pour promouvoir les dispositifs
innovants au collège angèle djib albine
ou encore michael moore à la fiche le
festival solidays revient du 21 au 23
juin à l'hippodrome de longchamp
événement musical et surtout caritatif
au profit de solidarité sida la 21e
édition était présenté ce matin dans les
locaux de la région ile de france à
paris et puis c'est le championnat inter
collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale le 6 mai 2019 se tient le 14
juin à la maurice attrape au programme
les phases finales l'occasion de fêter
les 20 ans de ce rendez vous proposés
par l'association déclic théâtre et du
sport également tout à l'heure avec la
présentation des prochaines manches de
coupe du monde de bmx c'est ce week end
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines
vingt-quatre heures après l'alerté
orange dans les yvelines les orages qui
ont fortement touché le département
ah vous voyez ces images tournées ce
matin sur la nationale 186 la chaussée
inondée à hauteur du chesnay rocancourt
d'autres inondations mais aussi des
dégâts de toiture et des chutes d'arbres
ont été recensés surtout dans le nord
est du département est les pompiers des
yvelines indique avoir reçu 175 demandes
d'intervention est le département n'est
plus en alerte orange mais reste tout de
même placé ce soir en vigilance jaune
par météo france pour la pluie et les
inondations
le département des yvelines est celui
des hauts-de-seine une nouvelle fois
réunis hier pour la première fois ils
ont organisé la fête inter
départementale du numérique c'était à
marnes-la-coquette un événement pour
mettre en avant les dispositifs
éducatifs innovants qui existe au sein
du collège les précisions de rayon
des jeunes mieux formés grâce à la
révolution numérique c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait montrer les départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine lors de
cette première fête du numérique
il faut que tous les endroits des
territoires départementaux
chaque élève a et la même chance de
réussir et l'espace numérique
c'est un outil formidable pour justement
aboutir à cette égalité des chances
par exemple à l'égard des décrocheurs on
arrive à repérer leurs carences et de
leur construire une orientation qui va
leur permettre de combler les trous
qu'ils peuvent avoir plusieurs projets
pédagogiques ont fait l'objet de
conférences et de partage d'expériences
concours robotique
ou encore exposition de maquettes sur le
collège de demain l'occasion également
de présenter un nouvel établissement qui
ouvrira ses portes en 2021 à mantes la
jolie et dans lequel le numérique aura
toute sa place
qu'est ce qu'un collège de demain
qu'est-ce qu'on aurait besoin pour
étudier le mieux possible et en fonction
de ça on a adapté tous les locaux aux
besoins des usagers
ce rendez vous d'aujourd'hui il illustre
finalement l'investissement de chacun y
met celui des collectivités locales
celui de l'état mais il illustre aussi
la réponse qu'on espère vivent aux
besoins de nos enseignants et de nous de
nos élèves
au cours de cette journée le département
des yvelines et le rectorat ont
également signé trois conventions en
faveur de l'inclusion
elle prévoit notamment le prêt d'outils
numériques pour les collégiens en
situation de handicap
c'est le premier forum européen de
l'économie numérique la paris ce cyber
week est au programme ce mercredi et
jeudi à la chambre des métiers et de
l'artisanat de paris le rendez-vous qui
concerne également la cybersécurité de
était de passage aujourd'hui à saint
quentin en yvelines
une délégation s'est rendue ce matin à
l'incubateur ski tubes que vous voyez à
l'image au programme cet après midi
visite des sites d'atos aux
clayes-sous-bois et d'airbus à elancourt
la cyber sécurité
le thème de la prochaine émission 7,8
échos diffusé ce vendredi sur tv 78 dans
l'actualité également la condamnation
d'eric heures rouleau le maire pcf de
limay écope d'une peine de 18 mois de
prison avec sursis prononcée par le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles fin
décembre l'élu de 61 ans sa femme et son
gendre avait tabassé leurs voisins à
fontenay saint père suite à une dispute
eric roulot échappe par contre à une
peine de cinq ans et d'inéligibilité
demandé par le procureur de la
république
une conférencière mardié à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
quelques jours après le verdict des
élections européennes elle avait pour
but de parler elle de la composition du
nouveau parlement de l'ue eux aboutir
abordé par non également aller à nouveau
à scénario de la politique européenne
présentée par les médias les images sont
signées nicolas kirilow liszt quelle
lecture faire des résultats du scrutin à
quoi ressemble le nouveau parlement
européen quelques-unes des questions
abordées lors de cette conférence à la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de l'ue vs qu expert de lieux
et journalistes spécialisés ont dressé
les prochaines échéances européennes les
élections désormais passer de nouveaux
enjeux se pose désormais constitution
des groupes de l'hémicycle ou encore
élection du président du parlement
pour nous c'est une législature qui
commence au parlement européen donc on
est qu'au tout début de
de ces grands enjeux pour peut-être pour
le citoyen qui a voté jeudi bon ben
maintenant mon vote est passée s'est
terminée il ya un parlement il ya des
élus non ça ne fait que commencer pour
ces élus vont devoir travailler ensemble
vont devoir constituer des familles des
groupes politiques
dans la salle une vingtaine de personnes
venues s'informer sur le nouveau
parlement européen
beaucoup de questions ont porté sur
l'écologie les cas du bric cité de
l'italie ont également été abordés
lequel d'ailleurs je peux donc du coup
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses sur le
cas italien
l'évolution à des à des parties
l'émotion dans les sondages et par
rapport aux dernières élections du pipi
2012 de la liga de l'évolution des
électeurs qui ont faim les deux camps
etc
c'était très intéressant vos devoirs
niveau social de voir niveau politique a
très intéressant on a débriefé quelque
sorte avec différents angles l'actualité
toute récente des élections et ça permet
de mieux se préparer à analyser les
événements qui vont suivre
prochaine échéance pour le parlement
européen la session inaugurale les 751
nouveaux eurodéputés se réuniront à
partir du 2 juillet à strasbourg il y
éliront leur nouveau président le sport
et du football un ancien du paris saint
germain et de l'olympique lyonnais sur
le banc de l'ess poissy laurent fournier
54 ans devient l'entraîneur du club
yvelinois pensionnaire de nationale 2 le
quatrième niveau national l'ex
international tricolore a signé pour un
an de contrat avec une année
supplémentaire en option l'objectif
c'est d'obtenir la montée en national
est laurent fournier a notamment été le
coach du psg de créteil de l'aj auxerre
et du red star
il sera présenté ce jeudi au stade léo
lagrange de poissy autre rendez vous
sportif c'est la coupe du monde de bmx
les manches 5 et 6 se déroule ce
week-end au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines est 250 ans et 250
des meilleurs riders du monde dont neuf
français seront en lice est michael et
demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude ont assisté à une session
d'entraînement une manche de coupe du
monde sera organisée ici ce week-end au
stadium de bmx de saint quentin en
yvelines à mes côtés deux acteurs qui
vont participer à cette manche de coupe
du monde julien sastre le sélectionneur
et romain mahieu qui sera compétiteurs
sur les
mme en q1 sastre comment se passent ces
derniers jours ça se passe bien
non plus sérieusement un peu comme
chaque semaine de coupe du monde que
l'on rencontre c'est à dire on essaye
d'être assez relaxe en début de semaine
puis petit à petit voilà les pilotes se
mettent dans la course monte en
puissance au fur et à mesure de la
semaine pour arriver voilà au maximum de
concentration sur le week-end samedi et
dimanche
pas trop de stress romain non ça va en
plus vu que vu que c'est la maison le
stress et est moindre que quand on va
rouler à l'extérieur et tout va bien le
groupe viennent tous de se regrouper la
en début de semaine
et l'ambiance est bonne comme d'habitude
du coup on est tous tous excités de
rouler ce week end justement vous êtes
le local vous disiez à l'instant de
l'étape
est-ce qu'il ya pas plus de pression ou
19 noms mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas plus
de pression plus de monde qui viendra
vous voir
non je en tout cas pour ma part non
planes et année dernière j avais pas eu
je sentais pas plus de pression même si
j'étais à domicile c'est limite si c'est
plus un boost c'est ça rend les choses
plus faciles d'avoir le public derrière
nous d'être heureux d'être chez nous
donc maintenant j'espère encore beaucoup
de gens cette année beaucoup de gens du
duduk ou à venir nous encourager
alors l'année dernière vous aviez fait
deuxième parce que cette année vous
allez faire la même chose
j'espère et j'espère même pourquoi pas
faire mieux donc l'année dernière
j'étais j'étais passé pas très loin de
de pouvoir en gagner une des deux donc
voilà cette année les objectifs ça sera
d'aller chercher de la chercher une
victoire
je viens ce qu'il a le potentiel pour
remporter une victoire aujourd'hui tout
à fait il l'a déjà prouvé sur d'autres
manches de coupe du monde notamment
comme romain viennent de dire sur sur la
manche de l'an dernier
et puis pour ce qui est de l'ensemble du
groupe ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
avec avec lui je pense que l'ensemble du
groupe a surtout eu envie c'est pas
tellement de la pression ça nous procure
de l'envi l'année dernière le public
était venu nombreux nous avait supporté
nous avait porté nous a donné beaucoup
de force
donc du coup et c'est surtout de l'envié
qu'on ressent je pensais que le groupe
dans son ensemble brossant comment vous
avez fait pour sélectionner ce groupe
est bien celle des sélections qui ont
lieu au fur et à mesure des manches de
coupe du monde qui seront qui ont lieu
sur soi les saisons précédentes soit la
saison en cours mais globalement le
groupe qui est là ce week end c'est un
groupe qui est habitué de l'équipe de
france c'est un peu le groupe cadre
les neuf pilotes là qui vont rouler donc
trois filles et 6 garçons avec des
pilotes issus voilà les fers de lance
issus de ce qu'on appelle nous notre
programme olympique et d'autres pilotes
issus un peu plus jeune de la jeune
génération qui constituent le programme
relève
vous visez combien de médailles c'est
toujours dur de conté avant l'heure
l'équipe de france a fait un excellent
début de saison cette année avec
notamment un triplé première une
première place de joris daudet deuxième
de gérer mercure est le troisième de
sylvain andré sur la première manche sur
l'ouverture de cette saison coupe du
monde à manchester
je vous avoue que chez les garçons on
espère faire aussi bien et les filles
sont pas en reste puisque manon
valentino a elle gagné la deuxième
manche de coupe du monde à manchester
également donc du coup voilà aujourd'hui
je pense que à la maison l'équipe de
france fait figure de favori donc un
nombre exact de podium je pourrais pas
trop m'avancer pour vous dire mais en
tout cas le maximum qu'on pourra aider
victoire est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on
est un peu dans une génération dorée
je pense oui ça fait ça fait deux trois
ans qu'on le montre sur chaque sur
chaque gros événement sur les coupes du
monde et les championnats de roche mère
du monde donc
donc pour l'instant mais la dynamique
est bonne sur chaque surface compétition
on est au rendez vous et on va faire en
sorte que ça continue qu'est ce qui fait
la force de cette équipe de france
le fait qu'à soit sérieuse mais en même
temps décontractée c'est un peu la
marque de fabrique effectivement de
l'équipe c'est à dire que le groupe est
capable à la fois d'être très rigoureux
très engagé quand quand voilà quand il y
a
le job à faire et en même temps très
relax dans les moments où on peut être
relax et je pense qu'une vraie force
mine de rien même dans une discipline
individuelle de cette équipe c'est
vraiment le groupe et l'état d'esprit
qui règne dans ce groupe et une bonne
ambiance tout le monde se tire vers le
haut les pilotes ne se juge pas entre
eux centraide et je crois que c'est
vraiment un très gros plus on va parler
de cette piste que vous connaissez par
coeur romain mahieu quelles sont ses
difficultés c'est qu'elle est très
technique par rapport aux puisqu'on a
maintenant sur les sur le circuit du
coup faut rester vraiment concentré tout
le monde la piste on n'a pas trop le
temps de ceux de pouvoir se relâchent et
de se détendre de ne pas faire attention
donc ça va sûrement rsa va être de
rester concentré jusqu'au bout pas faire
d'erreurs techniques pour pouvoir partir
à la faute
il ya aussi un paramètre qu'il faudra
prendre en compte forcément c'est
l'aspect climatique il ya beaucoup de
vent aujourd'hui on ne sait pas s'il y
en aura également ce week-end en quoi ça
joue le vent sur les performances c'est
plutôt sur sur les sauts en fête du
conte comme on passe beaucoup de temps
en l'air il ya des moments s'il ya du
vent qui vient de côté ça peut nous
gêner c'est vraiment le seul problème
après quand ça accès c'est pas c'est pas
très gênant et du bon centre à nice y un
peu tous les jours on a l'habitude du
vent après faut voir avec quelle force
devant aussi mais ce sera vraiment ça
s'il ya vraiment du vent le problème
après je pense que c'est lui qu'on roule
un peu en soirée ça devrait peut-être se
calmer et ça ça va nous offrir quand
même deux belles courses et de bonnes
conditions
il ya également un paramètre qu'il
faudra prendre en compte c'est la chance
forcément c'est un sport où il faut
quand même un peu de chance
alors moi je parlerais plutôt de
réussite parce qu'effectivement oui il
peut y avoir en bmx des situations avec
avec des chutes ça arrive fréquemment ça
fait partie de la discipline mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi savoir provoquer
la chance et se mettre dans les
conditions pour pouvoir provoquer la
chance comme c'est ce qui nous a souri
c'était cet élément là nous a souri
jusqu'ici n'y a pas de raison que ça
fasse pas aussi ce week-end on attend
environ 12000 personnes sur cet
événement est ce qu'on comptait sur
l'appui du public
évidemment évidemment l'année dernière
il était était beaucoup ceux des
présents pour nous supporter en on les a
entendus et nous ont aidés ils nous ont
poussés du coup on compte bien ont
conduit en voir autant cette année
un dernier mot pour eux ben déjà merci
pour ceux qui vont venir qui ont prévu
de venir et puis venez nombreux nous
donner de la force nous encourager et
-surtout- les encourager parce que l'an
dernier ça a été ouais on parle on parle
de douzième homme dans un sport comme le
foot bal à nous ça a été un pilote de
plus dans l'équipe et quels pilotes
parce que ça nous a donné énormément de
force il va y avoir du spectacle
d'ailleurs du grand spectacle du grand
grand spectacle monde donc j'espère
j'espère voir nombreux merci beaucoup à
tous les deux et bon courage pour cette
manche de coupe du monde qui je le
rappelle sont organisées à ce week-end
sur le stadium de bmx de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et elle et
quelques images de cette interview
signée également dossier anne bazire 80
concerts sur trois jours solidays
revient à la fin du mois à paris les
chances d'un festival organisé en
partenariat avec la région ile de france
depuis sa création plus de 3 millions de
spectateurs ont foulé les pelouses de
l'hippodrome et l'ani poker et audrey
chaillou était ce matin à la conférence
de presse de présentation 37 millions de
personnes vivent avec le vih dans le
monde
et même si l'accès aux traitements
évoluer progresse il ya encore 40 % des
malades dans le monde qui n'ont pas
accès aux traitements
solidays c'est dans moins de trois
semaines de festival en faveur de la
lutte contre le sida revient pour une
21e édition
c'est aussi un rendez-vous qu'on attend
tous parce que ça c'est un week-end qui
fait du bien c'est un week-end à terre
public c'est un week-end où on se sent
plus proche des autres où il ya de la
bienveillance de l'empathie ça me permet
d'assister à des colloques de rencontrer
des gens ou ensuite d'acheter des
bouquins intéressant qui nous permette
de grandir de m'éduquer
et puis ensuite de repasser à la musique
il ya tout qui est condensée dans ce
festival cette année encore
l'ile-de-france et partenaires un
soutien à hauteur de 800 mille euros la
région est particulièrement touché
chaque jour 7 franciliens découvrent
leur séropositivité
nous avons un grand festival de musique
populaire française et ça est
indépendant et ça c'est très important
culturellement c'est très important
c'est un festival qui a un supplément
d'âme un supplément d'âme parce que la
question de la lutte contre le sida est
majeur tu l'as dit pour l'ile-de-france
80 concerts répartis sur 3 jours le
festival attire chaque année des
nouveaux artistes mais aussi des fidèles
hocus pocus se reforme pour une tournée
anniversaire
solidays c'est un des plus beaux
festivals qu'on ait fait on a vraiment
des souvenirs particuliers où on s'est
retrouvé à jouer dans quarante cinquante
mille personnes
on nous a souvent programmés sur des
débuts de projets aussi quand s'était
pas lancé par exemple sur alta où
c'était incroyable sous le chapiteau en
ce moment on est à fond sur l'engagement
c'est un truc qui est qu'on a compris
c'est un truc qui est venu avec le
succès et qu'on a compris en se disant
on a un gros audimat il ya des grands
enjeux en ce moment dans notre époque
actuelle donc il faut qu'on fasse partie
de ça pour être solidaire c'est du 21 au
23 juin à paris longchamp l'an dernier
le festival avait battu un record de
fréquentation plus de 212 mille
spectateurs s'étaient déplacés
cet événement aussi est un classique
c'est un rendez vous annuel à saint
quentin en yvelines les vingtièmes phase
finale du ciq mythe se déroule le
vendredi avec 14 juin c'est à la merise
attrape c'est le championnat inter
collèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale dont tv 78 et partenaires et
pour en parler
plusieurs invités sur ce plateau nous
rayer keane louise bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le responsable du
secteur improvisation pour déclic
théâtre l'association qui organise cet
événement est également en plateau de
collégiens qui vont participer à ce
cycle mythe 2019 alors il ya marie
guillaumin et mohamed kacem ça donne
bonsoir à vous deux ans a alors vous
représentez mari pour vous le collège de
la mare au sol à coignières et pour vous
ment et m'aide c'est le collège du
village attrapé vous allez d'ailleurs
vous avez affronté lors d'une des demi
finales
2 de cet événement qui est le cycle
mythe 20 ans déjà nous y incline pour ce
cycle mythe
on imagine que ça tient à coeur chaque
année à des clics de leur proposer cet
événement bah tout à fait pour nous
c'est c'est l'événement en fait sur
lequel on a bâti nos fondations enfin
qui sont nos fondations en tout cas
parce que parce qu'en fait tout ce
qu'ils ont pu voilà brillé sur les
planches de déclic
en tout cas pour la grande majorité sont
issus de ce travail là et comme on le
disait d'ailleurs avec les élèves là
tout à l'heure quand on patiente et
c'est aussi c'est aussi pour nous une
manière de c'est un champ des possibles
c'est à dire que on
créer des vocations quelque part en
disant voilà c'est aussi une possibilité
pour votre avenir de 2,12 bien de vous
en servir dans votre parcours
professionnel
ou bien de vous dire c'est possible
aussi d'être comédien ou d'être ou
découvrez les milieux du thé des métiers
du théâtre mais en vain en politique ça
fait aussi d'un temps que vous vous y
participer ça fait 20 ans que moi j'y
participe en ski la queue est-ce qu'il a
évolué depuis sa création aussi depuis
sa création on peut me dire que le cycle
mi temps lui même il existe depuis 20
ans donc ça c'est le championnat inter
collèges sur saint quentin en yvelines
mais moi j'ai participé en tant que
joueur quand c'était condensé sur trappe
dans les années 90
et oui il a évolué il a évolué parce que
parce que les années font qu'en fait il
a une visibilité
voilà qui qu'ils à un rendez-vous
maintenant c'est assez important tv 78
il participe grandement aussi parce que
voilà il ya ce partenariat qui nous
permet de le rendre visible et puis
surtout aux élèves de de se revoir vitam
aeternam sur les réseaux mais il a
surtout évolué parce que aujourd'hui on
a la chance d'avoir aussi des anciens
élèves des collèges qui ont ça à coeur
et qui donne aujourd'hui les ateliers
donc je pense par exemple à entendre à
bois madame diane cdcc alexandra
feignait ils viennent et du 8 juillet
ils viennent de des collèges de saint
quentin ils ont participé au cycle 8
et aujourd'hui c'est eux qui retransmet
de ça donc cesser
la boucle est bouclée et puis maintenant
il n'y a plus qu'à il n'y a plus qu'à
laisser aller accompagné bébé pour ce 6
mai que le 14 juin il y aura donc les
demi finales suivies de la grande finale
les demi finales le programme le collège
des prés de montigny le bretonneux face
au collège alexandre dumas est de
maurepas et donc aussi les collèges
chasser l'autre demi-finale de la mare
au sol collège de la mare au sol qui
tenant du titre qui a gagné l année
dernière à coignières face au collège de
trappes collège le village de traduction
je me tourne vers ses participants
pourquoi on va commencer avec vous marie
pourquoi participer à ce championnat
donc ça vous tenait à coeur parce que
c'est toujours un bon moment à passer
enfin on s'éclate plus que l'enjeu
premier qui pourraient pour certains et
de gagner voilà on n'est plus là pour le
côté amusant vous jouez avec les autres
et partager un bon moment avec tout le
monde
mouais mais ceci pour passer un bon
moment c'est pour ça que vous y
participer oui moi c'est pour pas pour
passer un bon moment et en même temps
c'est super parce que on parle avec des
personnes que l'on connaît pas on
s'amuse avec eux on rigole avec nous on
plaisante avec en fait on fait tout
ensemble même si on se connaît pas et ce
qui est fou c'est que en faisant ça on a
l'impression qu'on est super proches
alors qu'on sait jamais vu et ça c'est
un sentiment qui est whaou qui est trop
qui est qui et qui est vraiment trop
bien qui est fort cet exercice de
l'improvisation qu'est ce qu'il
représente pour vous pour moi il
représente pour moi je trouve que
parce que ça permet peut-être de se
dépasser aller au delà d'une timidité
peut être ça enlève la timidité
on sent meilleur oms on s'épanouit plus
qu on est souvent dans dans si on est
toujours dans dans ce sens s'amuser
c'est mauvais et ça c'est quelque chose
qui me permet de nous amuser et d'aller
voir autre part que là où on est c'est
l'état d'esprit qu'elles et ils marient
est-ce que c'est plutôt de l'excitation
ou êtes aussi peut-être stressé à la
proche de ce cycle mythe c'est quoi
votre état d'esprit
c'est plus de l'excitation de l' envie
d'y aller d'être à ce moment là plus que
du stress parce que le stress on l'a
quelques secondes avant de rentrer sur
la patinoire mais une fois qu'on y est
rond ou pensent juste aux fêtes de
s'amuser et de passer un bon moment et
ça se prépare comme ans du coup comment
vous là vous l'avez préparer moi même on
est on a tous une équipe et on
s'entraîne sur ça ce qu'il faut
apprendre ce qui pourrait nous aider et
et comment comment en fait le but de ça
c'est que le but c'est que c'est qu'on
s'amuse c'est la buse on l'a compris le
bon esprit
le programme aura redonné la parole à
anne aurélia qu'il le programme c'est
pas grave alors le programme ces demi
finales finale c'est ça si on peut
rappeler peut-être les règles de base
d'un match d'improvisation déjà la règle
de base
ils ont déjà très bien dit c'est la
rencontre avant tout ça voilà on parle
d'affrontements tout ça mais ça c'est le
folklore pour le public nous c'est vrai
que ce qui nous intéresse c'est ce qui
les intéresse eux ils le comprennent
très vite c'est la rencontre après le
qui va gagner
j'ai envie de dire quand on est sur
scène on a déjà tout gagné et mai mais
les règles dans l'esprit des règles
c'est de toute façon moi en tant
qu'arbitre je sais que je n'interviens
que si des moment donné on joue
on joue l'enjeu plus que le jeu en fait
et
et ça une fois qu'ils l'ont intégré en
fait ils deviennent il y
il se crée un vrai espace de liberté
dans dance dance dance et chose très
codifié très cadrée sur lesquels ben
voilà on peut pas profiter de l'autre
pour faire une blague on peut pas parler
tous en même temps
en fait ils apprennent un petit peu les
les règles de société un c15 microcosmos
comme le dit mohamed il a raison on
connaît pas les gens mais on va s'amuser
ensemble et ce qui est bien c'est que on
est sur un territoire qui est très riche
de diversité et on vient à mettre tout
ça dans un pot commun
on a des codes communs qui sont les
codes de l'impro et et il ya là on y va
quoi çà çà çà çà çà marche et je
rappelle cette phase finale du vingtième
cycle mythe ce vendredi avec 14 juin
c'est à partir de 20h30 à la merise
attrape la billetterie est encore
ouverte et pour ceux qui n'y seraient
pas à ce cycle mi temps il sera
rediffusé sur notre antenne tv 78 dans
les jours qui suivront cet événement
merci à noyal keane merci à mohamed et
merci à marie et bonne chance à vous
pour ce cycle mythe 2019
on termine ce journal avec notre petite
visite du mercredi dans les salles du
cinéma décès de cinéma du territoire ce
soir lui beaucamp du ciné 7 à elancourt
présente la programmation au micro de
marylène iapichino il était de passage à
cannes et vous allez le voir il a ramené
de nombreuses trouvailles dans ses
bagages
[Musique]
cette semaine aussi 17 deux très beaux
films issus de la compétition d'ailleurs
opaque de la compétition cannoise ce
très beau 72e festival de cannes à
festival réputé très dense et très riche
effectivement donc le premier ces civils
qui est un thriller français de justin
triais avec virginie efira qui est en
train de devenir une star est déjà une
star et adèle exarque coupleuse qui a
été découverte dans les films notamment
de kechiche à la danse et je vais pas
raconter l'histoire c'est assez intense
assez bouleversant c'est l'histoire
d'une fille d'une scie qui va devenir
romancière et qui regroupe une actrice
qui va s'approprier son histoire c'est
assez vertigineux c'est à découvrir donc
on sale au ciné set cette semaine le
film est sorti la semaine dernière est
le deuxième film c'est le jeune à m
alors le jeune ahmed prix du scénario
pour les frères dardenne à cannes
encore une fois un très très beau film
très prenant très bouleversant ça
raconte l'histoire d'un jeune garçon qui
s'appelle ahmed qui a 13 ans et qui est
tiraillé on va dire entre les lé désir
de pureté de son image parce qu'il est
très religieux et la ville qui sont donc
à découvrir dans nos salles cette
semaine au ciné 7
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant au nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
sur tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]